calori barile go back suo epicentro
mezzo di ragazzi sono famigerati suo
appeal room con che cavolo sto dicendo
anche se questo è un gioco dove si ci si
spacca metà allora taglierei tutto
quanto eravamo rimasti che se vedete qui
questo bellissimo cerchietto non avevo
sbloccato l'ultimo fottutissimo
maledetto oggetto però ho sbloccato
tutti gli altri quindi vorrei provarlo
mi sono tenuto questo momento per c'è
adesso perché voglio assolutamente
vedere come funziona considerando il
fatto che non ho provato tutti i
soggetti novico sbloccato per ora ma chi
non lo conoscesse ragazze quel gioco che
più fai danno più da punti quindi un
gioco molto educativo da questo punto di
vista ma proviamo vedere cosa come
funzionano stimi samp premoli così in
attimo giusto prevedere che cosa fanno
beh non è proprio il massimo quando
volete è per carità di dio
cosa vuol dire spara non fanno niente va
bene allora fai tutto clear mettiamo un
attimo il missile qua sotto dei devo
colpirlo proprio il missile
questa cosa era la vita sto male come ha
fatto non conoscerlo prima ma scusami
fantastico può anche andare in alto ma
sto malissimo puoi provare che figata
no raga femmine geniale sta roba è
geniale basta cioè non è finito di
discutere al geniale
ora mettiamo uno qua un altro 4 vediamo
non so se funziona sta roba è raga però
credo di sì almeno è quello che voglio
provare a fare e poi mettiamo un sacco
di roba tipo questo qua se si sa che
esplode a questo caso fa rimanere
attaccato in teoria dovrebbe essere una
buona combo e mentre rimane attaccato
mettiamo il cannone al plasmon ditemi
quello che volete la gara stavolta
secondo me facciamo un casinò c'è sto
provando a mettere tutte le cose
possibili e rave non so che c'è un
miliardo di soldi tra l'altro da usare
acquario con piranha pure beh però
spostano che perfetto allora
ricapitolando secondo me faccio un danno
della madonna però non è detto quindi o
mettere più cose possibili cosa posso
mettere le seghe anno volendo posso
cospargere tutto di mine sei tanto pè
riguarda ok muli bueno moglie ma dalla
quanti soldi so ancora quanto pare
troppo
c'è un migliao finalmente vai let's go
mi sa che ho fatto veramente un casi
madonna che tattica è successo
esattamente quello che no ho solo messo
ogni lato all altro missile
volevo metterlo verso l'alto i hope e
pirla che danno che fa
si no la vera chiama che basso male su
un genio un genio del male va però l'ha
fatto 10.000 punti come noccioline
fantastico l'altro razzo volevo metterlo
verso l'alto l'omesso storto l'omesso
porca vacca ho sbagliato emma o vide
niente mi è rimasto bloccato personaggio
molto bene così
rifacciamo me lo fai perfetto questo
questo volevo molto bene male che guarda
madonna che male
o cose cose accadono
no la beva sto male ok mi sa che la
tattica delle spine adesso è decisamente
funzionato
ottimo devo arrivare al record reagan
non so quanto ci metto però ci devo
arrivare assolutamente c'è una donna che
donava vera colle veramente tantissimo
non so se riuscirò mai a farlo era
veramente pitt che le tattiche da sadico
ma funzionano tutte quasi 11.000 punti
normale comunque dai togliere io i
piranha e farei delle altre robe perché
i piranha cioè funzionano fino a una
certa non c'è una cosa posso mettere
nell'aria in generale let's go proviamo
a vedere ma la disco di cosa fare
non c'è niente che ci rende tutto più
figo non ci sto fa niente
una cagata la disco cosa faremo questo
un sacco di danni che mi dà un sacco di
ha certo la donna che male da disco è
veramente inutile al mondo proprio ego
vedersi quindi ok
beh direi non male quasi 11.000 punti
not bad men note belle mai me not dead
allora ragazzi cambiano un po di roba
vediamo se riesco a fare delle robe
decenti un po più [ __ ] di questo
raccogliamo hirai cosi qui sotto e
mettiamo roba più power ancora ok
proviamo così giusto per curiosità
fa sempre male della madonna però vabbè
perché c'è un crollo c'è un pollo che
guida il missile cosa vedo che comunque
mi fermo sempre su quel numero ii e cioè
che faccio più di tanto sempre più
10.700 sempre lì li togliamo questi in
qualche modo lo farò rega cielo me lo
sento
cantona ghiaccio secondo me alla fine
fortissima canon ajaccio quindi lo
terrei e le metterei pure un altro che è
stata d'altra parte speriamo di fare più
di 10.700 per favore beh va beh
quanti punti follia va bene sono
contento che è male di star facendo
vabbè basta che superiamo i 10.700 sono
contenti o 10.800 invece strada sono
stato più bravo gaga sempre per quel
punteggio lino ma niente male
va bene dalla prima fare dei cambiamenti
visto che se non sempre tutto uguale
allora però a sostituire le spine di
sopra da questi togli li definisco
alcuni pali i pali dovrebbero togliere è
però mi servono più cav h fai provare a
vedere come va così giusto per capire se
ti statistica ci pali che fanno
malissimo i pali
che male ticino mio quest'ultima ha dato
una botta allucinazione mi piace un
sacco il palo in sé per sé perché
ritiene di fermo tantissimo però le
altre armi devono darsi da fare sono
comunque da abbattere 10.800 lei non era
male dice che abbiano batterò mai più
attenzione 10.500 non male per quella
fine il danno è sempre quello di più o
meno simile 7 a fort cavalca prima avevo
fatto meglio adesso proviamo la roba
nuova che dite alla primo gravità zero
che ancora non mi ricordo se ho provato
meno ma non mi pare gravitazione 0 vai
tutta l'acqua
giusto per capire cos'è e poi vorrei
vedere parte che non ho più soldi prova
cannone gravitazionale neanche questo
l'ho mai provato canale gravitazionale
lo tagliamo camera al plasma mettine 1
gravitazionale randon perfetto aspettato
minima su un sacco di spazio proviamo
così giusto per vedere come funziona ma
no ben capito cosa fa la gravità zero
prova ma mi fate sapere qual è la vostra
arma preferita nei commenti non sono
sincero perché ce ne sono talmente la
mia per ora è questa questa dove
il missile che ti porta veramente figo e
la seconda sono i cannoni questi qua
anche se non ho ben capito meritiamo lo
sono veramente un'infinità di armi ci
sono però sono veramente [ __ ] se
riuscissi a battere 10.400 10.800 di
punteggio ha ritrovato la tattica
migliore però è difficilissimo pro forse
stavolta ce la faccio sono confidente
dai forza vacca per quattro punti con
cui non ho capito cosa perché hanno né
gravitazionale non mi interessa non mi
piace allora cella con mostro a basta
non posso permettere che così fa così
tanti punti
va bene vediamo tra curiosità e precari
destro ma deve arrivare sì ma prima che
il mostro vidoc iii muore l'avevo già
provata la c'è lavoro morso ma non me lo
ricordavo si sono ghiacciati mostri
porca vacca sollecita distruggere la mia
stessa arma va bene raccontando che mi
mancano ancora un botto di danni
c'è un ok perfetto se come stavolta sono
messo meglio delle altre 600 sembra
decisamente messo meglio delle altre
volte se non casca buonissimo molto bene
c'è ancora mostro che spinge 10900
record dei record di oggi non male più
di così è veramente difficile 10.929 è
veramente impossibile fare più di così
c'è già tantissimo come lascia però
lascia non ne vale così tanto la pena
lega c'e la prova anche per tutti volte
l'ho provata non mi ha dato tanta
soddisfazione prova vi mettiamo la prima
vedere un attimo giusto per vedere se me
la ricordo bene
le dipartite perché è stato stato lascia
però lasciano veramente niente perché
costa 900 che fa cagare perché messo
delle dell'eroe dei dei cosi laterali
perché secondo me temi più fermo di lato
infatti danno però non lo so lo
scopriremo solo alla fine ma non penso
di aver azzeccato di cos'era ho
sbloccato una roba non so come ho fatto
non sbloccato una roba che era
velocissimo quindi non l'ho visto ho
sbloccato una roba raga non so come ho
fatto devo vederlo assolutamente 8.000
ho fatto cagare
cos'è che ho sbloccato come si vede come
ha fatto come ho fatto prima
quello cambio personale mi sembra che si
è sbloccato un personaggio nuovo sono io
scemo
secondo me sono riusciremo peccato direi
quindi ragazzi di sacrificare tutte le
mine e vedere se riesco con il
teletrasporto a fare la roba che ho
fatto l'altra volta ci provo era gava
che non mi ricordo più come si fa tipo
una roba del genere che continua a
sbattere di sotto
let's go proviamo a fare una roba da
madonna del guarda
no no
dovevi fare canestro due volte ci sono
degli arti che continuano a cadere mi fa
piacere se le corazze care
una direzione giusta e bloccato così
vabbè facciamo che sigla no no solo
scherzando sto scherzando e facciamo che
la prossima volta
se riesco sblocco questo e lo vediamo ma
ci metterò una vita quindi la sosta
registrazione andare avanti mentre voi
vedetevi il video poi settimana prossima
se siamo arrivati lì ci metterò una
settimana
tengo computer acceso non è un problema
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
spero che siate contenti dei risultati
io lo sono moltissimo però bisogna fare
più danno bisogna fare più danno perché
dobbiamo raggiungere assolutamente sta
roba qua ma ce la faremo è per forza
cosa che i ragazzi se il video vi è
piaciuto lasciate un commento è un mi
piace
iscrivetevi al canale e non ci vediamo
[Musica]